ce sera peut-être leur futur employeur
ces étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin sont venus se
renseigner sur cette entreprise carole
est en master en management
elle cherche à travailler dans
l'événementiel et les relations clients
ça avait l'air très sympa et font des
stages justement dans beaucoup de
domaines différents
donc j'ai des saints c'est vais voir ce
que ça peut donner et puis nous ont
donné également leurs coordonnées sur
linkedin est un site internet voilà
organisée par cinq étudiants de l'ue vs
cul dans le cadre de leur formation ce
forum des métiers se veut être un lieu
de rencontre entre élèves et
professionnels un moyen d'y voir plus
clair après le diplôme
au total sept entreprises ont joué le
jeu alors nos intervenants de plusieurs
entreprises manquons à l'entreprise
thalès on a le groupe sort d'alain sauf
on a aussi la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion la face des yvelines donc
vraiment c'est très diverses
la plupart sont enfants sont d'anciens
étudiants m et c'est donc notre
formation est donc ça permet de
aux étudiants de m1 pour se projeter
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir qu'est ce
qu'ils vont être plus tard beaucoup pour
des z pour détruire des stages où
trouver de l'alternance c'est pour ça
qu'on allait personne ici qui ont
proposé des offres de stages l'idée
c'est qu'on puisse leur donner un peu de
visibilité sur la praye diplômés voire
qu'elles sont là panel de jobs qui
peuvent s'offrir à eux comme par exemple
la partie projet chez talentsoft nous ce
qui nous intéresse en tant qu'entreprise
entre en entreprise c'est de pouvoir
venir récupérer un peu de de feedback de
la part de l'étudiant voir un peu
comment se passe leur faim de diplômes
détecter de nouveaux talents également
et puis pour eux c'est effectivement
bénéficier des premiers contacts dans la
matinée une soixantaine de curieux a pu
échanger avec les intervenants
ce forum des métiers était le premier de
cette ampleur un événement qui devrait
être pérennisé sous cette forme